do you think that there's a common
thread between the survival of jordan
peterson when the
the penguin random house staff
threatened to walk out over his new book
and then
the political staff rebelled against ben
shapiro writing their playbook
and then jk rowling's book caused the
uproar with hatchet last year
is that lesson to learn that if you're
big enough you're immune from being
cancelled
um yes because while while um
while these businesses are not purely
based on economic motivations
they still have economic motivations and
jk rowling i think is the best example
because she controls the rights of the
harry potter franchise
she controls uh the sort of um the way
that the franchise is represented
she controls the uh the ascent the
essential decision-making capacity
and so the buck stops with her and she
makes the money from it um which means
she can't actually be cancelled if
anyone else wants to make any money off
harry potter
so is that has she constructed her
business to be like
universal studios got to come to me when
they want to do a new theme park and the
merchandising and
and she she gets to be able to sign off
on uh the sort of um
tenor and tone of the thing as well you
know like does it fit with the mythos
which gives her phenomenal power over
the harry potter franchise as i
understand it if i'm wrong
someone in the comments correct me but i
looked into this recently because i did
a bit of a thing a few segments on
them trying to cancel her and they can't
cancel her because
if they cancel her nobody gets any harry
potter
and i mean probably billions of people
want harry potter
you know hundreds of millions at the
very least uh you know she's
she's probably like the most successful
british author ever
so there's there's just no canceling her
because she holds this
point of leverage and industries die
if they don't get what she's providing
and so the the activists on twitter have
been whining
impotently and it's been very amusing to
watch to be honest
and jk rowling for anyone doesn't know
her high crime refers back to what we
were talking about with the definition
of woman
she made the argument that woman is
adult human female and if you get rid of
that you get rid of women's rights
activism
which is not wrong and this makes her
a horrible turf do you not think that
it's mad you've got
jk rowling was very much in the
zeitgeist at the time though you know
she's
current and doing stuff jordan peterson
had been in rehab for 18 months
like and yeah and people had just taken
this heritage
of him again shapiro like ben ben does
his
thing like he's out there talking about
stuff
jordan had been in russia tied to a bed
trying to trying to sweat drugs out of
his system
yeah but i think um what jk rowling is
just the most obvious and easy example
to pin down
right because you can see exactly the
lynch pin that when jk rowling gives up
the right to make editorial decisions
about harry potter franchise
she's cancelled right um but it's it's
not so easy with people like john
peterson and ben shapiro
because their their um
their staying power is based on
something a bit more
um in intangible uh it's it's
respect and influence and sort of
gravitas and that can be manipulated
with the right disinformation campaign
absolutely which i think is why the
times recently
uh put out a lie about him being
diagnosed with schizophrenia an attempt
to discredit him as an intellectual as
in his mind is
somehow you know insecure and not not
he's not sane or something like this
this wasn't true
jordan peterson released the full
interview of the times i listened to it
he didn't say they've been diagnosed
schizophrenia have you seen i haven't
seen that yet what what's the what's the
well yeah you can actually you can
actually go to lotus.com and we've got
an article uh refuting
this on there because um yeah it's just
not true the the the times has claimed
that he was diagnosed with schizophrenia
he hasn't been uh i don't know why
they're claiming this
but i can only assume that they're
making up this outright lie
in order to damage his public prestige
as an intellectual in order to discredit
him within conservative circles
and wider the wider sort of normie
public in order to
essentially just get rid of him because
he doesn't agree with certain things
does he
man that makes me feel so uncomfortable
you know like that guy's been through
hell
over the last 18 months and you sit down
to have an interview i haven't seen the
interview yet
but like it's it's on his youtube
channel it's just the audio yeah
oh yes i noticed it was black black
screen when i rolled over a preview it's
in my watch later
but um yeah man that makes me so
uncomfortable like it shouldn't be the
case that someone who's been through
absolute hell comes back and because
people don't like his ideas which
for anyone who's ever read anything that
jordan's done are not
controversial he's got hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of hours of him
lecturing students
available on the internet go through
like scrape out you know at least with
shapiro
um he has that webpage on his site of
all of the things he's ever said which
he now
regrets or wishes that he hadn't said or
whatever which i also think is quite a
noble thing to do that's a good idea as
well to be honest
no one ever has and there's no rogue
tweet
from peterson there's no lingering
uh sort of bodies in the cupboard for
people to get out there's just
misinterpretation that's all that they
have left
but i mean yeah i i hope that
the more situations that occur like that
where
unwarrantedly people come after
prominent public figures
that they don't succeed because there's
been a few periods that you yourself
included where
it has succeeded yeah um
well yeah i mean you know you're the the
point about john peace and
what he has been through uh as has been
the consequence of a media harassment
campaign against him
you know the reason that he fell into
this hole and frank
i mean like you know i i'm i only have
sort of a middling
fame on the internet uh and in the wider
world but
even from my middling position
i mean you can see how great the beard
is right like it wasn't this great like
two or three years ago
um it's i'm not even joking it's really
stressful it's very stressful
when you have a lot of eyes on you and
there's a lot of pressure coming at you
and peterson is like you know 10 times
bigger than i'll ever be
and so it's it's one of those things
that's if it's bad enough for where i am
it must have been really difficult for
him and you
like like you were saying you go and
watch your stuff you can tell that he's
a very
emotionally aware person you know and he
probably has to be to be a clinical
psychologist
so he's very emotionally connected to
things and to other people and he cares
about these things you know he's been
he's cried on live streams when thinking
about other people's suffering and stuff
like this unashamedly you know and it's
it's very brave actually
to do this and i've seen lots of
leftists mocking him for showing his
feelings
well hang on a second i thought that's
what you wanted out of men you know what
are you doing you know don't
when he opens up don't stab him you know
christ but
um but yeah so for for peterson i can
understand why this was just too much
for him to handle
uh why he ended up falling down this
this sort of rabbit hole and
having to spend a lot of effort dragging
himself back up
and like you say you know if you watch
any of this stuff he's talking
essentially he's essentially giving you
the sort of like best dad advice that
can be given
you know get your house in order
ultimately he is but it's great advice
for young people not just young men but
i think young men need it more than
young women
because there are lots of social support
structures for young women everywhere
because of feminism
but young men definitely i think need
this kind of guidance where it's like
look
get your house in order sort yourself
out clean your room get on
you know get on the the business end of
actually doing
something and improving your life and i
mean
you know i've i've taken his advice to
heart you know i think a lot of other
people have as well
and it really does work it's just about
taking responsibility for yourself
and if that is if that's his high crime
and that's the great offense
that jordan peterson has committed well
i guess we're all in trouble aren't we
you